the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of eight news now or next
our media group
you know i hear that they're standing in
line for hours tonight on politics now
new rules and
long lines businesses that can start
allowing more people in
while health officials trying to get the
vaccine out quickly plus
these dollars thankfully are a little
bit flexible
with how we can utilize them money for
schools renters and small
businesses the state's economic stimulus
being pushed through the legislative
session
you identify as queer i identify as
bisexual
and sexual and we meet one of the newest
members of the hispanic legislative
caucus
assemblywoman cecilia gonzalez
from eight news now this is politics now
thank you very much for joining us i'm
john langler signs of progress in the
fight against the coronavirus
hope for some relief to businesses that
are struggling to get through these
health guidelines
starting on monday some of nevada's
restrictions will be eased
governor steve sisolak laid out a 75-day
plan to fully reopen the economy
starting on monday indoor dining places
of worship gyms
and gaming floors at casinos bowling
alleys as well
they will move to a limit of 100 people
or 35
capacity on thursday the governor also
gave a vaccine
update and he says more than 390 000
doses have been administered
however there is concern it's not
happening fast enough
you may have seen how we're experiencing
long lines at vaccination
sites the clark county convention center
is an example today with seniors
70 and up standing for hours
with all due respect to the hard work
going into this and while i know you
don't
run the southern nevada health district
is it time for the state to team up to
try to help fix
technical issues to perhaps do
drive-through vaccination sites
they're doing those drive-throughs in
california
well we have uh my team has been in
southern nevada they're working with
southern nevada to help alleviate
uh these situations we're taking federal
advice
as it becomes available on this we
certainly don't want our seniors our
most vulnerable
standing in line for hours you know i
hear that they're standing in line for
hours and then the
health district is telling me that you
know 15 of the people aren't showing up
for appointments and there's duplicate
appointments
this is an enormous a herculean task to
undertake
the governor also expressed support for
getting children back
in schools and he pointed out 16 of
nevada's 17
counties have already taken that step
however as we know
most of the clark county school district
is still doing distance learning at
least until early march
now to look at the state legislative
session a hot topic in the session so
far
fixing nevada's unemployment system
lawmakers started talking about this
issue in senate bill 75 a bill that was
requested
by dieter testimony from the department
included the technical changes among
staff
how much money employers are paying into
the system and borrowing money from the
federal government
however the focus of the event quickly
turned to why it's taking
so long for nevadans to get their money
dieter blames it on a tsunami of fraud
and in order to confirm fraud dieter
says it needs to identify
each claim and that's just taking up
resources
this head-on fraud has really
um slowed down the entire process of
being able to get these people
paid we want to get them paid trust me
but
um we also don't want to send bad money
out the door
deter says it's recovered 100 million
dollars in fraudulent payments already
and prevented 2 billion dollars from
being sent to fake accounts
no vote was taken on that senate bill
some criminal justice and police reform
bills are also starting to be written up
in carson city
lawmakers promised to take measures to
deal with bias training after a summer
of black lives matter protests
senate bill 108 would require any person
employed in the criminal justice system
to take implicit bias and
cultural competency training it's
sponsored by the senate judiciary
committee
a bill requiring police officers to
complete those trainings already took
effect back in 2019
this bill would apply to other people in
law enforcement mainly
the courts and attorneys it does not
have a hearing schedule just yet
democrats are making another run at
passing a dignity in
death bill it's the fourth straight
session a physician assisted suicide
bill has been
introduced the 2019 version passed the
senate but not the assembly
this version is sponsored by state
senator dallas harris
in this case a secondary physician and
two witnesses would have to sign off on
administering the lethal drugs
oregon was the first state to pass a
dignity and death measure about 20 years
ago
so far there about a thousand people
have taken advantage
more than 90 percent of them were in
hospice care at the time
another big topic is economic assistance
more than half a billion dollars in
federal money is being set aside for
renters and schools here in southern
nevada
the spending was approved by the interim
finance committee this week
in all 208 million dollars is going to
rental assistance programs
nevada's division of housing estimates
it'll help about 20 thousand households
162 million dollars will be sent spent
here in clark county money will go
directly from the state's account right
to the landlord
the clark county school district is
getting a larger chunk of money as well
about 350 million dollars
but it's important to note this will be
on top of money that's already in the
distributive school account
the money is slated to help reopen
schools safely and outfit them with new
technology state senate majority leader
nicole cannizzaro told 8 news now some
ways the money could be spent is to fund
some alert summer learning
teacher training and sanitation one of
the things that some of these funds can
be utilized for
for example are things like addressing
learning loss with students so how do we
start to do that
with providing assistance for summer pro
for summer learning programs
with training for our educators on how
to
keep the classroom safe and sanitized to
protect against
the virus once we start to open up
schools there's money in there to
address
kids who might be either in an english
language learner
program or in a lower income community
and so have had harder access
harder more difficult time accessing
our educational facilities during the
pandemic when they haven't been able to
attend in school and so
there's some guidance in there that
allows for us
to help with those programs to address
some of the needs of those students
these dollars thankfully are a little
bit flexible
with how we can utilize them so to put
this in perspective the entire general
fund for the state budget a year
is about 4 billion dollars the 630
million dollar federal stimulus approved
a month and a half ago
it's a hefty chunk of change we're gonna
have a link to apply for the rental
assistance and the other information
about this
at eightnewsnow.com the first bill to
pass and be
signed by governor sisilak was money for
small businesses
assembly bill 106 was fast tracked
through this week
it puts 50 million more dollars into a
pandemic
grant program called pets oracle mana
explains who could get that funding
[Applause]
we took a hit by having to reduce staff
in some areas
like many nevada small businesses sonya
pedowick's consulting company has been
crippled by covet 19.
she applied for the pandemic emergency
technical support or pets grant last
fall to get help
i met all of the qualifications as
outlined in the portal
but with so many asking for aid the
money just wasn't there
now there's hope i'd love to put it back
into workforce right and be able to hire
back
staff and talent offset some of my
overhead costs would be
you know a blessing for many of our
small businesses the funding they were
provided was a difference
between staying open or closing their
doors the same goes for nonprofits such
as united citizens foundation which
provides mental health services to kids
and families
staff say the money made a difference so
the pets grant allowed us to fill in
fill in that gap to
be able to see some kids that did not
have a pay source that did not have
insurance
those in limbo right now can only do one
thing i'm
waiting and being as patient as i can
orca mana 8 news now
because the state gives this out it's
accessible to small businesses with less
than 50 employees
many of those companies couldn't get the
ppp loans before to stay afloat
corporations though cannot apply for it
the state says all funds have to be
distributed by june
30th there are a couple of bills up in
the legislative session that deal with
pets and animal issues
senate bill 103 for example would stop
your home insurance company from raising
or canceling your insurance based on the
breed of your dog
many companies charge higher insurance
if you have a dog like a pit bull or a
rottweiler
assembly bill 101 allows veterans to
give cbd or cannabis products to their
animals for medical treatments
neither of those bills have had their
first hearing scheduled just yet
next on politics now criminal justice
reform in the legislature
how do we provide services to folks to
really address why they're offending in
the first place
freshman freshman assemblywoman cecilia
gonzalez talks to us about what
[Music]
welcome back to politics now
there are several new first-time
lawmakers up at the state legislature in
carson city
including some of the youngest members
of the legislature ever
three freshman democrats are joining the
hispanic legislative caucus
and christian cazares has been talking
to them christian hello that's right
john well this week i talked to
assemblywoman cecilia gonzalez she
represents district 16
which is in the central portion of clark
county she is half
thai and half mexican i asked her about
representing her heritage
and criminal justice reform you're kind
of like a part of this new wave of
latinos and also a
younger generation that's going uh into
into the leadership role um what's that
like
and also how do you think that'll kind
of play a part in
in working down the road and kind of you
know working also
uh to get support from both sides of the
aisle
yeah great question thank you so much
you know it is such a privilege and an
honor
um to join my latina and latino brothers
and sisters up here
i think that um you know
it matters you know on the campaign
trail i can't tell you how many
um text messages i have you know
screenshoted and saved where folks are
like you know
you're mexican i'm mexican you have
three mexican votes in this household
representation really matters and it it
matters in a way where folks can look
at their elected officials and their
leaders and think to themselves you know
that's a latina
or that's an asian american woman you
know
i can see myself in that person i can
see myself in in their story
and that i can also become an elected
official as well and that i deserve to
be a leader to represent our community
i was reading a little bit about you and
i i saw that obviously you have a big
passion for the criminal justice
system reform what comes next in your
mind
and you know how much change do you
think that you
can accomplish during your trip yeah
that's a great question i think that
criminal justice reform
as you've seen in the last couple of
years has really gained a lot of
bipartisanship you know our
our communities are hurting our families
are hurting
our prison system you know is hurting in
terms of
not being funded to what they need to be
right and so um
unfortunately here in nevada we
incarcerate higher than the national
average and so
i'm really looking forward to working on
bringing
change on how we view offenders we could
see some sort of bill being introduced
by you
hopefully soon yes i did submit a bdr
to address the prison population in a
national health pandemic i'm very
excited
to work on that with a lot of different
community partners and stakeholders i'm
currently in that process
is it safe to say that you know that you
are like an lgbt
ally and if so you know being nevada
being so liberal and
so far um you know they've they've made
so many steps moving forward
in in in that area um is that something
that maybe you see yourself kind of
spearheading some sort of uh you know
action or something down the road
yeah so um great question i love the
question
um i actually do identify as queer i
identify as bisexual
pansexual and so um not only am i an
ally but i am the
a member of the community and i'm the
first asian
american lgbtq queer elected official in
this state
um so that's a lot right and so um
i definitely am looking forward to um
you know with sessions to come
and time to come continue that work of
advocacy for the community
very interesting christian did
assemblywoman gonzalez give any other
insight on some other measures that
she's working on up in carson city
actually yes she said that she's also
working on a bill to make
lower income people a protected class
another related
climate change uh bills that's that's
all i have for you right now john back
to you in this right prince thank you
christian appreciate that
next on politics now charged with murder
but on house arrest
the i team talks to local police about
their concerns and defense attorneys
about what
of mysterywire.com you're watching
politics now you've probably
heard about house arrest before or bail
or bond
alternatives to being in jail while
someone is awaiting trial
but accused murderers turns out they're
not always in custody
the i-team's vanessa murphy takes a
closer look at this issue
at least 35 defendants charged with
murder in clark county are not
in jail the circumstances vary a woman
who police say shoved an elderly man
off a bus a security guard accused of
killing a man on the job
and several alleged acts of domestic
violence
at least nine are accused of killing
children
most of them their own he paid less
for his bond than the cost of my child's
funeral
veronica melton's son giovanni was 14
years old
her ex-husband wendell melton is accused
of shooting him back in 2017
because he was gay today he's on house
arrest
awaiting trial utterly perplexing
i don't understand the system metro
deputy chief laz chavez says on average
30 to 40 people charged with murder are
not behind bars
that's about 10 percent of open murder
cases right now
it's frustrating it's frustrating for
the police department metro police keep
track of electronic monitoring and house
arrest
some of the worst crimes which is the
taking the life of another human being
is that the one where you get to go home
or not
i would argue that it's not you're
innocent until proven guilty
ozzy fumo is a criminal defense attorney
just because the accusation is made
that someone has committed a crime
doesn't mean they're guilty of that
crime you know
there's a process for it the burden
falls on prosecutors to convince a judge
to keep the person
in jail in 99 of these cases
the district attorney's office seeks a
significant bail district attorney steve
wolfson says that may be as much as a
million dollars in some cases
it's always up to the judge the judges
make the ultimate decision
the judge considers whether the
defendant will be a danger to the
community
according to metro from 2018 to 2020
eight defendants charged with murder who
were on house arrest were accused of
committing new crimes
including assault sex offense and more
the judge also considers whether a
defendant will willingly return to court
the department reports no defendants
charged with murder fled over the past
two years
but in 2019 christopher prestopino was a
no-show
he's accused of killing a woman and
dumping her body
in the desert he posted a 500 thousand
dollar bond
police found him at his house while he
was supposed to be in court
and took him back to jail it took the
wind out of the sales of
all of us thinking that this is the one
who meets the criteria
for house arrest the i-team examined
court records to find out whether
certain judges were more likely to grant
bail house arrest or electronic
monitoring
for defendants charged with murder and
we found
no major trends i think now we're
finally
equaling the scales of justice because
we have judges who understand the law we
will continue to
investigate these crimes what happens
afterwards
needs to be in my opinion needs to be
looked at and may be reconsidered
wolfson says a defendant out of custody
can sometimes delay a case
if a defendant isn't in jail he says
their legal team may not hesitate in
asking for continuances
veronica melton says she's been waiting
more than three years
for justice but the action and the
result is still the same i still have a
child
vanessa murphy eight news now
in one case our i-team found bail was
reduced for the defendant because of the
coronavirus
according to court records though he has
asthma metro police say as of thursday
15
inmates have kova 19 and were in
isolation deputy chief chavez who you
heard from there insists there is room
for defendants charged with murder to be
safely
housed metro reports 36 vacancy
the second impeachment trial meanwhile
of donald trump is underway in
washington d.c
house managers have argued the capital
attack cost taxpayers millions of
dollars but more importantly
has compromised american national
security washington d.c correspondent
alexander limon reports
good evening and once again today the
house impeachment managers played videos
including some of their fellow lawmakers
remembering how they used pieces of
furniture inside the u.s capitol
to make makeshift weapons in case they
needed to fight their way
out of the mob one of the impeachment
managers congresswoman diana degette
argued the mob came because former
president donald trump
invited them their own statements before
during and after the attack made clear
the attack was done
for donald trump at his instructions
and to fulfill his wishes
lead impeachment manager congressman
jamie raskin said trump knew his
supporters could become violent
because it happened before when
extremists plotted to kidnap
michigan's governor when responding to
extremist plots in michigan trump showed
he knew how to use the power of a mob
to advance his political objectives but
despite the case house managers are
trying to make
most republican senators say the
managers haven't proved
trump caused the attack particularly
remembering the defense has not yet
brought its case
where i'm sure they're going to show
footage of the president's actual speech
where he said
go and peacefully protest raskin told
senators there's no reason to believe
trump won't continue to promote violence
if he ever returns to office
would you bet the lives of more police
officers on that
would you bet the safety of your family
on that
would you bet the future of your
democracy on that
a conviction by the u.s senate would
block trump from running for office
again in the future
starting tomorrow we'll hear the defense
from trump's lawyers
reporting in washington alexandra limon
of course that was earlier in the week
the u.s attorney for nevada is one of
dozens that will be leaving his post
nicholas tretanich announced his last
day will be february 28th
drewtanich was sworn in in january 2019
after unanimous confirmation by the u.s
senate before that
he served as chief of staff to nevada's
attorney general at the time
adam laxalt